ALL RIGHT SAID GOOD MORNING AND
WELCOME TO TODAY'S- HEARING ON
THE BREADTH AND TAX ITEMS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA WILL BE
CONSIDERED FOR VOTE ONLY IN THE
COMMITTEE WILL NOT BE HEARING
TESTIMONY OR WITNESSES I ALSO
WANT TO NOTE THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEVINE HAS BEEN REPLACED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS FOR
THIS HEARING ONLY IT LOOKS LIKE
WE HAVE HAVE A QUORUM IS
HIGHLAND CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL BERMAN. HERE WHEN- GRAY
HAIR RESEND ROBERT RIVAS MAYES
HERE MOLEN PETRIE-NORRIS. QUIRK
YEAH THREE OF US HERE THEY ARE A
WE HAVEN'T QUITE RIGHTLY HAVE A
QUORUM AND I DO WE JUST WANT TO
MENTION THAT- THE BILLS THAT WE
ARE HEARING TODAY ALL ENJOY AND
I RECCO OF WE CUT ABOUT HALF OF
THE BILLS BASED ON COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE AND POLICY
CONSIDERATIONS SO WE'LL MOVE ON
TO FILE ITEM ONE AB SIXTEEN
TWENTY THREE RAMOS TO WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND. SECOND
RIGHT SO WE HAVE MOTION BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS A
SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS THE SILENT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ON AB SIXTEEN
TWENTY THREE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS IRWIN.
HI- WHEN I WHEN I AGREE. I AGREE
I AGREE SEN ROBERT RIVAS MAYES
MAYES ARE I AM MULLIN
PETRIE-NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS
ARTWORK NO WORK NO THREE OF US
THREE OF US R. I. C. A. R. L.
THERE ARE A LOT. FOUR SEVEN TWO
ZERO SEVEN SEVEN THE BILL- IS
OUT THE NEXT BILL ON OUR AGENDA
IS FILE ITEM TO AB SEVENTEEN
TWENTY NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
VOEPEL DO WE HAVE MOTION THE
SECOND. SECOND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OF MOTION BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK A SECOND BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS MOTION IS DUE
PASSED WITH PREPARATIONS MISSILE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON AB
SEVENTEEN TWENTY NINE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
IRWIN HI- WHEN I WHEN I GREAT.
AYE GRAY AYE GRAYSON.
ROBERT RIVAS MAYES MAYES ARE YOU
MULLIN MULLIN I'D PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS ARTWORK QUIRK I
THREE OF US RIVAS I SIERRA
SIERRA. NINE ZERO WITH PASSED
THAT BILL IS OUT NINE ZERO THE
NEXT FILE ITEM IS NUMBER THREE
A. B. EIGHTEEN EIGHTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHOI I DO WE HAVE
A MOTION AND SECOND. A MOTION BY
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND LENDS A
SECOND BY ASSEMBLYMEMBERS WHERE
TO GO- THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS THE
MEMBERS HAVE BEEN DISTRIBUTED
AND LIMIT THE DEDUCTION TO
PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHERS BEEN
SILENT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ON
AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS A MINUTE TO
APPROPRIATIONS. IRWIN IRWIN ON
WHEN I WHEN I GRAY HI REYES A
GRAYSON. ROBERT RIVAS MAYES. I'M
SORRY WHICH ONE. THREE I MAYES I
MULLIN MULLIN RIP THREE NORRIS
TURNER'S ARTWORK NO WORK NO
RIVAS THREE OF US HI THREE OF US
I SIERRA THEORIZE. FIVE THAT
POLICY EIGHT ONE THAT BILL IS
OUT WE WILL NOW TO ON A FILE
ITEM FOR AB NINETEEN ELEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL TOLEDO
MOVED. A MOTION BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK A SECOND BY
THE SECOND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS- THE MOTION IS TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS MS HIGHLAND
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB
NINETEEN ELEVEN THE MOTION AS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS- IRWIN
HI- WHEN I WHEN I WHEN I GREAT.
GREAT I AGREE SEN ROBERT RIVAS
MAYES MAYES ARI MOLEN MULLIN AYE
PETRIE-NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS
ARTWORK I WORK THREE OF US HI
THREE OF US ICING ARTICLE
SARATOGA. NINE TWO ZERO IT'S
PAST AT THE BILL IS OUT THE NEXT
ITEM ON OUR AGENDA IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AB IN NINETEEN FIFTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
REMOVED DR WORK FLOW THAT CAN
AND THE SECOND BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- THREE OF US MOTIONS TO
PASSED WITH CREATIONS ASYLUM
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON AB
NINETEEN FIFTY ONE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS IRWIN-
IRWIN ARMY WHEN. WIN I AGREE.
GREAT I GRAYSON. ROBERT RIVAS.
MAYES MAYES HI MULLIN. MULLIN
AYE PETRIE-NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS
ARTWORK ALL RIGHT WORK-
THREE OF US HI THREE OF US I
SEYARTO SIERRA ON. THAT BILLS
OUT NINE ZERO AB NINETEEN FIFTY
ONE IS OUT OF THE NEXT ITEM IS
FILE ITEM SIX EIGHTY TWENTY ONE
FORTY TWO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL DO I'VE MOTION THE
SECOND MOVE THE BILL. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. A MOTION BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK A SECOND BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS MOTION IS
DUE PASSED WITH. PREPARATIONS
BEEN SILENT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. ON AB TWENTY FORTY TWO THE
MOTION TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
IRWIN BY- WHEN I WHEN. WHEN I
GRADE. GREAT I GRAYSON
ROBERT RIVAS MAYES MAYES ARE YOU
MULLIN MULLIN AYE PETRIE-NORRIS
. PETRIE-NORRIS ARTWORK I WORK
AYE THREE OF US HI THREE OF US I
SIERRA SIERRA ALL RIGHT THAT'S
ALL NINE ZERO AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY TWO IS OUT- THE NEXT ITEM
IS FILE ITEM SEVEN AB TWENTY
THREE SIXTY THREE FIVE MOTION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
MOTIONS TO PASSED WITH
PREPARATIONS BEEN SILENT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON A B. TWENTY
THREE SIXTY THREE THE MOTION AS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS IRWIN
IRWIN ONLINE WHEN I RATE. GRAY
AYE GRAYSON ROBERT RIVAS MAYES
MAYES ARI MULLIN MULLIN I
PETRIE-NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS
ARTWORK HI BURKE I THREE OF US
HI THREE OF US I SEYARTO SARAI
THAT BILLS OUT NINE ZERO BILL IS
OUT- THE NEXT ITEM ON OUR A FILE
IS ITEM EIGHT AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT AUTHORED BY IRWIN
MULLIN THOUGH DON'T SECOND.
SECOND MOTION BY SOME QUIRK
SECOND BY SIMPLY REVIEWS THE
MOTION TO PASS TO APPROACH IS
SILENT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL I AB
THREE SEVENTY THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO PROBE IRWIN HI- WHEN I
WHEN WIN ON A GRAY. I AGREES OR
RIVAS MAYES. HIS OUR MOMENT.
WILL I'D BETWEEN. PETRIE-NORRIS
I WORK ON THREE OF US
THREE OF US ICE ORDER THE ORDER
THAT'S OUT NINE ZERO TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY IS OUT OF THE NEXT
ITEM ON OUR IS I NINE AB TWENTY
SIX TWENTY TWO BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MULLIN TO AYE THE MOTION
AND A SECOND NO MOVED. BACK I
HAVE A MOTION BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK A SECOND BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS MOTIONS TO PASSED
WITH PREPARATIONS MISS HIGHLAND
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON AB
TWENTY SIX TWENTY TO THE MOTION
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS IRWIN
IRWIN I WHEN. WIN I GRADE. GRAY
I AGREES. ROBERT RIVAS MAYES
MAYES AYE MULLIN. MULLIN AYE
PETRI. BETWEEN OURS ARE LIKE HI
WORK I LISTEN THREE OF US I SAY
ARE OUT THERE I BILLS NINE ZERO
AB TWENTY TWENTY TWO IS OUT THE
I ON OUR AGE IS FOR ITEM AB TWO
SIX ONE ASSEMBLY PETRI WE HAVE
MOTION A SECOND BILL MOVED. AND
IT'S- WAY THE MOTION
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK IN A SECOND
SIMPLY RIVAS AND TO WITH. BEEN
SILENT FOLLOW. ON AB THIRD FIFTY
THE MUCH IS TO PASS TO THE
PROPER. IRWIN IRWIN ON WIN. WHEN
ARE A GREAT. GREAT I AGREE.
ROBERT MAY. MAYES I MULLIN.
MOMENT I PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS OUR CORE HI WORK I
LOOSE THREE HI THIS I FIGURED
OUT ZERO AYE THAT BILLS ARE NINE
ZERO AB SIX ONE OUT OF THE NEXT
IS FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB TWENTY
SEVEN SEVENTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VIA PULLED WHY DO WE HAVE A
MOTION AND SECOND SO MOVED A
MOTION A MOTION BY SOME NUMBER
QUIRK A SECOND BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAYES THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS MISS
HIGHLAND PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ON AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS IRWIN HI IRWIN
ALL RIGHT WHEN. WHEN I GRADE.
REYES GRAYSON ROBERT RIVAS MAYES
MANNY'S ARE. HELLO I
PETRIE-NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS. ON
WORK LOSE THREE LIST ICE OUT
THERE TONIGHT THAT BILLS OUT
NINE ZERO EIGHT TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY IS OUT- THE NEXT ITEM ON
OUR AGENDA IS FIGHTING MY- FILE
ITEM TWELVE AB TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA DRIVING MOTION
AND A SECOND- MOVED. THE MOVIE
WAS ABOUT OF THAT MOTION BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK A SECOND BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS THE AMENDMENTS
HAVE BEEN DISTRIBUTED AND LIMIT
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
AUGMENTATION TO THE PROGRAM'S
CURRENT SUNSET PERIOD. IS
HIGHLAND PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MEASURE ON AB TWO EIGHT
EIGHT SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS IRWIN. AND I
NGUYEN. WIN I REALLY. GREAT
AGREE SO. ROBERT RIVAS MAY. MAY
ARM ALL. MULLIN HEY SO OF. MORE
I PETRIE-NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS I
WORK I WORK I LOSE. THREE OF US
I THEY ARE THEY ARE TO AVOID THE
BILL'S NINE ZERO AB TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY SEVEN IS OUT A B. TWENTY
EIGHT NINETY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VINCE FONG FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN IS UP NEXT DO WE HAVE
MOVED TO THE L. AS OF MOTION BY
SOME. QUIRK AS SEX FIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND WHEN- THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS MISS
HIGHLAND PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ON AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY EIGHT
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS IRWIN HI- WHEN I
WHEN I GRAY GREAT HI GRAYSON
GRAYSON I ROBERT RIVAS MAYES.
MAYES AYE MULLIN MULLIN I'D
PETRIE-NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS
ARTWORK ALL RIGHT BURKE ALL
RIGHT THREE OF US HI THREE OF US
ICING ARDO ZERO ON THAT BILLS UP
TO ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT- THE
LAST ITEM ON OUR AGENDA IS FILE
ITEM FOURTEEN AB TWENTY NINE
FIFTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIGHT
WE HAVE MOTION THE SECOND SO
MOVED. AS OF BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK IS SECOND BY I THINK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS THE
MOTION IS TO PASS APPROPRIATIONS
THE SILENT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ON AB TWENTY NINE. FIFTY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. IRWIN HI- WHEN I
WHEN I WHEN I GREAT. YEA I AGREE
SEN GRAYSON I ROBERT RIVAS MAYES
. MAYES MULLIN MULLIN I
PETRIE-NORRIS. PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS ARTWORK I WORK I
RIVAS LOOSE HI THREE OF US ICE
ZERO ZERO AND THAT BUILDS UP
THAT BILL AND ZERO OUT OF TEN
NEWS ZERO SO WE WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR OUR- I THOUGHT THE
WILL HOLD OFF FOR NOW. WE'RE
WITNESSING- WE ARE MISSING
ROBERT RIVAS ARE YOU MISSING MON
ON SO WE CAN GO BACK THROUGH ALL
RIGHT SO WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ANOTHER ITEM TEN MINUTES FOR
ADD ONS BUT WE WILL GO THROUGH
THE PUBLIC NOW. ON AB. SIXTEEN
TWENTY THREE THE BILL HAS PASSED
GRAYSON. GRAYSON ONLINE MULLIN.
MULLIN HI. ON AB. SEVENTEEN
TWENTY NINE THE BILLS PASSED
GRAYSON GRAYSON I. ON A. B.
EIGHTEEN NINETY NINE THE BILL
HAS BASS GRAYSON GRAYSON I. ON
AB NINETEEN ELEVEN THAT BILL HAS
PASSED GRAYSON GRAYSON I. ON AB. NINETEEN FIFTY ONE. GREAT
GREAT GUY. AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
TWO THAT BILL HAS PASSED GRAYSON
GRAYSON I. AB. TWENTY THREE
SIXTY THREE THAT BILL IS PASSED
GRAYSON GRAYSON I. AB TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT- WHEN THAT
BILL HAS PASSED GRAYSON GRAYSON
I. AB. TWENTY SIX TWENTY TWO THE
I. AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY ONE NOT
BILL HAS PASSED GRAYSON GRAYSON
I. AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN ZERO THAT
I. AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY SEVEN
THAT BILL HAS PASSED GRAYSON
GRAYSON I. BUT I JUST WANT TO
SPEND. THREE
OKAY.
HELLO MYSTERY THIS. MMHM YOU
MIGHT- OKAY WE ARE- GOING TO
HAVE ONE MORE ROUND OF ADDING ON
BEFORE INSURANCE. I'M AB SIXTEEN
TWENTY THREE THE BILL HAS PASSED
ROBERT RIVAS. ROBERT RIVAS. AB
SEVENTEEN TWENTY NINE THE BILL
HAS PASSED ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I. AB EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY NINE THE BILL HAS PASSED
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS SORRY. AB NINETEEN ELEVEN THE BILL
HAS PASSED ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT
RIVERSIDE. AB NINETEEN FIFTY ONE
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS I. AB
TWENTY ONE FORTY TWO THAT BILL
HAS PASSED ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I. AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY THREE THE BILL HAS PASSED
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS SORRY
. AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY EIGHT
THAT BILL HAS PASSED ROBERT
IVAS ROBERT RIVAS I. AB TWENTY
SIX TWENTY TWO THAT BILL HAS
PASSED ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT
RIVERSIDE. AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY
ONE THE BILL HAS PASSED ROBERT
RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS I. AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN ZERO THAT BILL HAS
PASSED ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS
I. AB TWO EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN HAS
PASSED ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT
RIVERSIDE. AB. TWENTY EIGHT
NINETY EIGHT THAT BILL HAS
PASSED ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT I. A
TWENTY NINE FIFTY THE BILL HAS
PASSED ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS
SIGN THAT- TWENTY MINUTES OKAY.
RIGHT WELL BEFORE I IN TURN I
WANT TO THANK MY A VERY VERY
HARD WORKING COMMITTEE STAFF-
YOU HAVE MADE THIS TRANSITION-
MUCH EASIER THAN- THAN IT COULD
HAVE BEEN SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND WE'LL LOOK FORWARD TO US
STARTING WITH THE SENATE. AND
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED.